Juan mamani dejó de cultivar el campo a
sus 60 años recorrió 982 kilómetros
desde copani su pueblo natal para
protestar no nos dejaron marchar
tranquilamente nos provocan no con
infiltrados ellos son los primeros
asesinos nosotros venimos a ser
pacíficamente nuestra lucha nuestra
lucha es justa
esta lucha tiene que ser hasta último
Hasta quemar el último cartucho Aún es
el reinicio de las protestas alrededor
de 60 peruanos han muerto y más de 1500
resultaron heridos debido a la represión
del gobierno de Dina boluarte según
denuncias de organismos de Derechos
Humanos
[Música]
pese estas cifras la lucha permanece en
Lima los indígenas duermen donde pueden
y se las ingenia para alimentarse con lo
que encuentran los manifestantes han
amenazado con recrudecer la protesta
porque el congreso rechazó el adelanto
de elecciones hay intenciones de tomar
el congreso hay intenciones
de tomar
como fiscalía es ministerio público
poder judicial
otras instituciones más donde campea la
corrupción al no aprobar el parlamento
el adelanto electoral el descontento
social ha crecido en contra de Dina
boluarte y al oler esa debilidad lo que
van a hacer es en lugar de replegarse
van a avanzar porque se van a dar cuenta
querida boluarte y el congreso no tiene
ni capacidad ni intención de resolver el
problema frente a eso yo creo que las
marchas van a continuar los bloqueos van
a continuar la violencia Va a continuar
Lamentablemente y ahí lo único que le va
a quedar al gobierno será seguir
reprimiendo con el saldo lamentable que
pueda venir adelante los manifestantes
inspiran su lucha en los ancestrales
incas afirman que no se rendirán hasta
conquistar sus demandas sin importar que
en el intento quizás puedan perder sus
vidas
[Aplausos]